and your responsibility for
having it failed?
I'll take all responsibility,
you know, I am the owner of the
team
and if it's not working, it's
really up to me.
And this is why, you know, we're
making a change.
Yeah, I'm disappointed. I'm very
disappointed and I don't
know and I don't think that that
owner is around
the organization like that. But
I was very disappointed. When
I heard this news because I
thought Brian Flores, he did
a great job of coming in there
and really change in the locker
room around
you talk about changing the
culture. That's exactly what he
was trying to do. And now
they're talking about. Well,
there's some disagreements
between like the future of
the hit
was
the general manager. They had
disagreements on
the quarterback and the future.
The franchise and I'm like the
head
coach is more important in a
general manager.
The general manager is
responsible
for going out there, getting
talent, but ultimately,
the coach knows exactly the type
of player that he wants. So to
me,
if anything, the general
managers should have been gone,
not Brian Flores.
And when you're coming in, as a
young black coach,
it takes a lot. It takes a lot
for him to step in there and
make a lot of tough decisions
and do things that make people
uncomfortable. But in order to
win, in order to win to the on
the next level,
You have to make people
uncomfortable. You have to make
some decisions that might offend
some people.
And, you know, for the life of
me, the goal was to beat
the Patriots, right? He beat the
Patriots twice. He'd beat Bill,
Belichick twice in one year
and to me.
How do you fire a guy off the
bat? You know, is this
personality too strong? Is he
not a do boy? Like you want him
to like,
I just didn't understand and I'm
very very disappointed because
any any owner, any?
Organization should appreciate
what Brian Flores was doing
for this team. And I'm just I'm
very, very disappointed. This
is definitely a step back.
I'll be stunned. If he doesn't
get another job and get another
job quickly. He's been more
successful than the GM and
that's where this doesn't make
sense. Right? He's been more
successful than the G of the
GM's. Been there
going all the way back. He was
the director of scouting going
back to 2007. Miami Dolphins,
been bad. Team for a long time.
Been a GM since 2016. They have
done, had some great team since
2016 in the disagreement, from
which I continue to hear
was that Flores wanted to draft
Herbert, which would have been
a better pick then.
It was okay. I don't want to
come down onto her. Justin
Herbert would have been a better
pick Brian Flores. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait,
you see?
Come on man. They can't win with
tool.
They can't win with to it. They
just can't win with tool and
I think Brian Flores, probably
wanted DeShaun Watson,
but when you look, and you go
out there and you see the type
of aggressive style defense that
they play they, you know,
rebuilding offensive line. And
then you have to or and every
time to or gets hit, or he drops
back. You're
thinking interception, you
thinking injury
and to me, you just can't play
football like that. When you're
afraid of your quarterback
getting constantly getting
hurt. You're afraid of your,
your quarterback
throwing an interception.
You know, I just,
I wasn't sold on to either. I
love them at Alabama,
you know, he did his thing,
but in the pros He's Just Not
That guy, he's getting better.
He's an average Quarterback.
He's nothing special about to
us. Just it's nothing special
about them on a. Professional
level Jack. That's all I'm
saying.
I agree with you. I agree with
you and you but you could see
Greer and you could see Ross,
the owner getting together and
making The Pick of to it, right?
That they collectively
had trumped Flores who is a new
guy to the program and go?
No, we're going to take to uh,
so then they're just going to
go out together and go all. If
you miss this, we have to
continue to ride down this path
to go down this and Flores is
going. No, I said, I was against
really beginning.
I'm still against this where,
when and I have good defense.
Fence, you know, we decided
10-win season. Now, we had
a nine win season. It's because
of what we're doing, within
the foundation of this program
and they're still stuck on. So
you got this tug and pull,
right? You got two guys at the
top, who want one quarterback.
You got the coach, who's winning
the games, who wants to
go a different direction and
use. It's not specific to Miami
Dolphins. This happens in other
places, right? Where you have
coach and GM or front office's
want
to do different things. And it
always seems to come back to
the quarterback position. My
guess is that another team it
maybe Chicago, Go it. Maybe
shoot any of these openings New
York.
Another team is going to very
quickly. Go Brian Flores,
a guy who now has experienced
the guy who was just trending
upward, maybe faster than any
young coach and football. Any
new coach in football. He's a
perfect higher for any other
program.
I think it's insane. I think
it's absolutely insane. That
after three seasons, especially
the way, they're trending that
you would move on from Brian
Flores to me. It's one of the,
it's one of the single biggest
front office mistakes
that I've seen maybe in the last
five or ten years.
Absolutely, and you see a man,
you are chilling. You see a lot
of these people sending these
texts these tweets man because
I felt the same way like I
thought he was doing
an excellent job. I thought he
had full commander of the locker
room. I thought he was really
changing the culture and
bringing some toughness. He
beat,
Bill Belichick twice in a year
who's done that. Like not many
have done that. You know, I'm
saying.
And I'm just, I'm just so
disappointed. I've
listen, I've played against the
Dolphins. I've been following
the Because when was the last
time the Dolphins were in
the Super Bowl?
Proof. Was it one?
Last time? I know they went
undefeated was that 72 to 78
1972. That was the year. I was
born. That's right. Me too.
So mean to me, but you know
what? Maybe this is the best
thing for Brian Flores. He got a
chance to go down there and
really get some, some coaching
experience
and wherever he goes
to the next place.
They're going to get a damn good
coach, but also they're
going to get a guy that's highly
experienced. So I'm
rooting. I know. We're both
rooting for Brian. Floors.
He'll bounce back on his feet.
No question about it and maybe
It's in Denver.
Yep. Yeah, that's right. That's
a good one too. And but you do
you know it's bad management to
is when you lose seven games
early in the year and then you
went eight out of your last
nine. It's not like it was the
opposite.
They got hot towards the end of
the year. Yeah yours. I don't
know. Let's move on. It's like
that's when you know, there's
something there's something
fishy with that when our let's
get to the next one, which is
the Giants. This is a recent.
It's sort of a breaking news or
they move on from Joe. Judge.
How surprised are you to hear
that?
I'm not, I was some, I was more
surprised to hear that. Joe
judge got a head coaching job.
I'm like, I was in the Patriots
organization. I did never knew
Joe. Just like who the hell is
Joe judge, you know and all of a
sudden he
gets his head coaching job and
he's yelling. He's talking
about a clown show in the
Washington football team and
you can just see his
inexperience. And for Joe
judge, maybe it was a money.
Grab to get as much money as he
possibly could. And then now
he can go back and be an
assistant and he doesn't have
to be the front guy, but I was
really On that the Giants
hired this guy and he's
organizations organizations.
They keep hiring. These guys.
Keep firing them. No stability.
It's crazy to me, man. And he's
all billion dollar companies
and they don't know what the
heck they're doing. It's just
like they're flushing money down
the drain
and it's like, do you evaluate
football? Like, do you have
really good people? Football
people around you to let you
know when a decision is good or
bad. Are you just doing this
off of analytics? I just don't
understand these organizations
anymore, bro.
You some that one up. All right,
let's get to another
fire. That we have. The Bears,
Matt. Nagy is one that you
could probably go back to about
week, five or six, maybe week
eight, at the latest. And you
knew this one was coming
the Bears.
Let him Coach out the season
because it seems to be
what they do. It's part of their
process to let them, no
matter how bad it gets. I'm
going to let you burn down with
the house that you built
Maggie gone.
Where the heck do they go from
here,
man. Let me let me tell you,
this is no surprise to me and
this is something that I've
been. Calling for for a while.
You know, Matt Nagy wasn't good.
He just wasn't good.
I mean for him to come in and
give Andy Dalton a job. That's
the thing that really pissed me
off
because you know, you can't give
a guy, a job. We're all
professionals. We're in that
locker room with fighting and
clawing for our families for our
team. And you give a guy
a job. Like who the heck is Andy
Dalton for you to give him
anything?
What has he done? What has he
won?
You know I'm saying, is like
Andy Dalton, you're giving him a
job. And when met Maggie, did
that being a guy from the
Chicagoland area? He's very
disappointed and I knew the
Bears would not have a great
season. Then you think about the
defense, all the wasted
time,
all the talent. All those guys
have gotten older. Kim Hicks.
Has gotten older
Khalil Mac. Eddie
Jackson. He's, you know, they
need to move on from him.
Paying him, 14 15 million bucks
a year, and he's stinks up
the place. So if it's me, once
again, I'm looking at a gym
called. Well, I'm looking at a
are being at me. I'm looking at
a buyer left with somebody that
can come in and work directly
with Justin fields.
And really just take be able to
take him to the next level.
I'm right there with the
offensive coach. That's what
Nagy was brought in there to do
and they never played good
offense, a scored 18 points per
game on offense, this year.
He's had two quarterbacks an
opportunity to do it for
Biscay. Justin Fields.
I mean, if anybody should be
impatient, it was Nagy.
Instead. He's playing the
patient game and by Vikings
that's a, that's a place who was
pretty patient with their
coach, coach. Jammer, eight
years. He had,
you know, some great defense has
if you go back three or
four years, top of the league
that is falling off since sort
of post covid. Really since the
covid-19. He's and they've been
at the bottom of the NFL. Now,
Zimmer that final game without
Kirk Cousins, who was out with
covid as
they went in there to play the
Packers. He is on his way out
from the Vikings.
Look, man, and he said it to me
and they tried everything they
could in the eight years that he
was there. But to me
the Vikings just need, they need
some fresh young energy. They
just need something fresh. They
need to get rid of
Kubiak as the sun. Kubiak. What
does named Clint Kubiak
the offensive coordinator? I
think he's adorable.
They need to get rid of him.
Justin Jefferson
alluded to it many of times that
he's not happy with
the offense and he's your star
player. Adam thielen
the starting to get a little
older. He's starting to get
hurt.
Dalvin cook. It is still very,
very efficient.
But at the end of the day, man,
you got to move on and you got
to get a hit a new head coach in
there. That's going to bring
some energy, bring some
excitement, get that defense
back flying around playing.
Well, they're getting older.
So,
you know, you look at you. Look
at this job. You try to figure
out. Well, they still guaranteed
Kirk Cousins. 35
million dollars this year. So,
do you as an organization? Do
you pay 15 20 million of that
and try to trade him,
or do you keep them in the pay
him a full 35?
Million dollars, like what
organization guarantees Kirk
Cousins, 35 million bucks. It's
just ridiculous. I'm happy for
Kurt. But at the end of you're
trying to win a championship,
it's not going to be like that
and encourages play well for
them.
Right. Yes. Yes, and their
defense is have just gone. He
sort of took them up and they've
come right back down
ever since I think Zimmer will
link all in as a defensive
coordinator somewhere and I
think we'll see him as all and
he's creative. I mean,
shoot, he does things that screw
with Aaron Rodgers mind.
So he's a creative mind and I
think he'll be a good fit. 65
years old still, got some good
career out of a new Energy. New
coach will be heading into the